In recent decades,
it has been normal to consider the
tenants of the White House,
the president of the United States has
the most powerful person in the world
give you a things they might be changing
or maybe they've actually already
changed.
Have you heard about the Chinese
presidents?
Well,
of course you have because I'm sure
you're a very avid visual politic view
app now.
You see Donald Trump himself in
statements collected by the Washington
Post describes the Chinese president,
Xi Jinping as the most powerful leader
that China has had in the last century,
which is as good as saying that Xi
Jinping is the most powerful Chinese
leader of all time.
More and more analysts wondering if he
isn't in fact the most powerful
political leader in the world.
Yes,
it's true now while trying is economy
and its army are still on a second level
of to the United States.
Trump seems to consistently be losing
his influence over the world and indeed
his own country,
and so when you go over to China,
you can see that the situation is pretty
much the opposite.
We'll wait,
wait,
wait.
Trump is losing his influence in the US.
I mean,
how could this possibly be the case?
He wants to be.
Everyone's friends.
Have one scene is rather sweet tweets
lately.
Why would Kim Jong UN insult me by
calling me old when I would never call
him short and fat?
Oh,
well,
I try so hard to be his friend and maybe
someday that will happen.
Yes.
It's definitely no surprise that the
United States is losing its influence
over the world in just a few months.
Trump has gone from nuclear war to
school,
the odd fights.
All right.
Anyway,
back to the serious stuff.
The fact is that although Tszujing thing
isn't the president of the world's
leading power,
he does control China's leadership
tightly,
a country which is one of the most
important economic engines on the
onyx.
Of course for Beijing.
Trump has been something like the
lottery Jackpot.
Nationalism and Donald Trump's mistakes
have allowed Xi Jinping,
the president of the world's largest
dictatorship to present his candidacy,
has this sort of global political
leader.
In January,
2017 of the Davis Forum,
Xi Jinping promised that China would
become nothing less than the champion of
globalization,
of free trade and even the fight against
climate change,
thus Beijing aspirants,
but its grasp on the terrain that has
been lost by watching it to mention,
well,
you know,
freedom and so all those other sorts of
apparently unimportant things,
Adi,
by,
by the sun,
Shins are,
you'll push out and
comes off.
Now what happened in the last Chinese
Communist Party Congress,
how much power does Xi Jinping have and
what does he wants?
Well,
we're going to discuss all of this,
but first,
let's take a look at China today,
but new China.
You think that China is still a country
where people live in deplorable
conditions,
breaking them backs been miserable
wages.
Well,
I'm sorry,
but the reality is you're actually
pretty wrong.
If you think that 2018 will be the 40th
anniversary of China's reform and open
policy in this country.
It's changed a lot in that time.
China is no longer a low income country,
but indeed a middle income country
tree
taking price differences into account is
it that purchasing power parity of about
$16,000,
which is bigger than both Columbia and
Brazil,
comedy has changed and nowadays services
are the most important activity example
in electronic commerce,
the sector in which the country is
beating Europe and even the United
States.
China represents no less than 40 percent
of all global transactions.
The same can be said of a mobile
payments which is so popular in this
country that it's market reached five
point $5,000,000,000,000 in 2016,
which is 50 times more than the United
States could be described as.
Not Bad.
I mean that growth has been so large,
but just in the last six years,
China's private consumption is growing
by two point $5,000,000,000,000 and
announced that equals India's entire
GDP.
Therefore,
when you visit one of those giant
Chinese cities,
it's not at all uncommon to find a city
full of skyscrapers,
billionaires,
and high speed trains.
Hold on just a second because China's
poverty continues and in general,
there is a really large difference
between the countries,
cities and the countries,
rural areas which remained poor,
very poor.
In fact,
they're so poor that 43 million people,
almost the entire population of Spain,
by the way,
still live in extreme poverty,
earning less than $1 a day,
and not only that,
almost 40 percent of Chinese people
still live at fairly low economic level.
Although the situation is much better
than a few decades ago.
This is all true,
but as I said before,
things are changing very quickly and we
can no longer think of China as we did
2010,
even just five years ago.
Way
You talking about poverty is an
interesting fact.
Do you know how the Chinese government
fights against poverty?
Well,
one of its main strategies is actually
creating new businesses and cooperatives
in the poorest of communities.
To this ends.
The government has granted almost
$400,000,000,000 in small loans to help
launch several companies and they not
only focus on money,
but also unculture.
The evening news is filled with tales of
rejuvenated communities and villagers
turned entrepreneurs heaping praise on
Mr c dot and the government for
providing loans and new apartments.
Javier Hernandez,
China correspondent for the New York
Times.
Yes,
yes.
I know Xi Jinping in practically every
country leader talk a lot about Chinese
style socialism.
The truth is that this is just a
reference to a kind of capitalist model
locked up within a dictatorship.
China isn't an ideological dictatorship,
Norris,
socialist or communist one.
It's just simply a dictatorship.
Having said that,
now let's talk a little bit about aging
thing.
The person leading this new China with
almost total power CGMP,
the leader
born in 1953.
We could say that Xi Jinping is a pretty
interesting dude.
On the one hand,
he's probably the Chinese leader who's
had the most contact with the West.
His daughter studied at Harvard.
His sister even lives in Canada,
and he has visited the United States
several times.
In fact,
in 2012 when he visited the United
States as vice president of China,
he made a somewhat peculiar stop.
He went to Iowa.
Well,
at this point you're probably wondering,
well,
why did he go to Iowa?
Well,
the fact is that in 1985 when she drink
thing was a young party,
county secretary in China,
he traveled to Iowa to investigate
agriculture related issues,
so in 2010 we went to see the family
that had stayed with at the time and he
brought them presence.
Pretty cool,
right?
In addition,
the president,
she's Yankee side.
It doesn't end there.
He's also known to love Hollywood
movies.
There is also another side to this since
he became China's highest authority five
years ago because government has been
characterized for having the most
censorship and repression for a very
long time.
We only need to take a look at the
latest cybersecurity law,
which seeks to control even more of the
Internet in China by restricting
anonymity in doing this is to such an
extent that also social network accounts
have to be backed by ANA identifying
citizen further.
It's been decades since China saw such a
strong leader.
We could say that all this propaganda as
well,
it greatly,
but that's not really surprising now is
that
the fact
is that in these five years,
Xi Jinping has made several changes in
China starting with the army reform and
they're very active foreign policy.
We saw it here at visual politic,
how Xi Jingping has done invested
national resources towards foreign
policy.
A good example is this new silk road
macro project which aims to invest
hundreds of billions of dollars in
several countries,
but generally that greatest commitments
has definitely been the fight against
corruption and this is seriously,
yeah,
sure.
Aging thing came to power.
If a one and a half million members of
the Communist Party have been sanctioned
and nearly 300,000 different
prosecutors,
including 43 members of the central
committee,
there's more within the framework of
this fight against corruption.
$13,000.
The officers have been dismissed and
it's more than 50 generals have been in
prisons.
Of course,
as you might expect.
Not everyone sees this battle as clean
and honest.
It's a selective anticorruption
campaign.
It's nature is the selective protection
of corruption.
When you purge some corrupt officials,
you're protecting the others,
you protect the corrupt system and you
protect correct people who support you
about tall Chinese activist.
Yes.
Xi Jinping has mostly relieved his
political rivals.
Coincidence,
of course.
It's very clear that teaching thing has
gained a lot of power in these five
years.
This was certainly observed in the last
Chinese Communist Party Congress,
the most important political event in
the country,
which is held every five years.
Yes,
19th congress.
The Chinese Communist Party,
Congress held between October the 18th
and 24th 2017 was quite peculiar,
especially because it may have been the
most austere congress that the Chinese
Communist Party is celebrated in many,
many years.
On this occasion,
some amenities,
they were removed out.
Some examples.
Well,
among other things,
there was no lavish buffets.
There was no hairdressing facials and
tailoring services.
I mean,
all of these used to be offered for free
to participants and it's almost become a
tradition,
but if this was the congress at which Xi
Jinping's adoration reached its highest
point,
something that,
as you can imagine in China,
means being put on an almost now like
level years ago.
I said he would be China's most powerful
leader since dms helping.
I was wrong.
He is now China's most powerful leader
since Kevin Rudd,
Australia's former prime minister.
See,
this congress led to the decision that
these so called Xi Jinping thought
should be included in the communist
party constitution.
This may seem a bit strange,
but it actually means that Xi Jinping is
no longer just another leader.
He is in fact the leader,
the leader whose words formed the
parties own ideology.
It means see is essentially unassailable
if you challenge.
See,
you are challenging the party and you
would never want to be against the
party.
Bill Bishop,
publisher of the Sinocism newsletter.
So far,
only males and Dong has received such an
honor in life,
but that's not all.
Apparently a president's mandate is
limited to 10 years,
which means that this would be Xi
Jinping's last time,
but during the military,
because no successor was considered
during the congress,
which leads us to believe that Xi
Jinping may be at least aspiring to a
third term Chinese universities
scrambled to open centers to study
president and Ping thought,
but anyway,
but he owns the Chinese border.
This congress helps define three major
priorities for the Chinese government in
upcoming years.
First,
there's the economy,
which means fighting poverty and opening
up more to the world.
Seconds,
there's the idea of launching even
stronger foreign policies.
And third,
start worrying about the environments
and you know,
even though I said there were three
priorities that is kind of a fourth and
it's actually a pretty clear one.
And that's consolidate the communist
party's power.
And this is because we know two things
for sure on the one hand that Xi Jinping
and the Chinese Communist Party will
stay for a long time.
And on the other hand,
China will reclaim its role as a
superpower.
So the reality is we're going to have to
get used to taking Beijing into accounts
and now it's your turn.
We've got an important question.
Who Do you think will leave power first?
Will it be Xi Jinping or Vladimir Putin?
Well,
you can leave your answer in the
comments below as well as in this survey
and I really hope you enjoyed this video
and please do hit that like button if
you did.
And don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday.
Also,
don't forget to check it off and said,
reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine.
And as always,
thank you for awhile.
Nah.